we should really find a way to help in
cells those who are involuntarily
celibate and we should do it in a way
that does not include forcing women to
have sex with them which has actually
been suggested by some what David what
on Earth are you talking about so let's
back it up in cell is short for
involuntarily celibate and it's more
than just being involuntarily celibate
meaning you'd like to be sexually active
but you're unable to find a partner
um it also has a sort of entire
subculture
and unfortunately there have been
elements of incel that have been
interwoven with mass Shooters in some
cases which have not uh gone unnoticed
and more broadly there is a concern and
I believe it is a warranted concern that
in general it's not just mass shootings
there is broader anti-social rather than
pro-social behavior that emanates from
this group that is in many cases
disaffected in many cases depressed
using that as a colloquial term not
necessarily clinical depression but just
dissatisfied and sad about the status of
their lives Etc
and I believe we need to find a way to
help these folks including to find
healthier role models than the people
that they often end up worshiping folks
like Jordan Peterson and Andrew Tate so
we have to consider the circumstances
first you've got a group that among
other
grievances with Society they're upset
they can't find a romantic partner
there's loneliness
there's isolation the suffering of
rejection in many cases and the reason
that it would be important to find a
very specific way to help this group of
people is not just that if we can
improve someone's life it's a great
thing to do but there's this
self-fulfilling prophecy that happens
often within the incel community where
it's bad for society not to help them
the very isolation and rejection Etc
that they suffer leads them to the path
where they find negative Role Models
like Jordan Peterson and Andrew Tate and
then they end up blaming everyone else
for their misery instead of maybe
looking more at themselves and changing
themselves and they end up adopting some
of the worst traits of the people that
they follow
it's not just Jordan Peterson and Andrew
Tate there's all sorts of like Charisma
coaches and pickup artists and all this
different stuff and it makes them even
less desirable to the very people they
are trying to appeal to so we've got to
figure out how to do something in cells
are often portrayed in a negative light
in society as well and we know of
individuals within the incel community
that have embraced hateful ideologies
sometimes the anger at the world and for
heterosexual in cells the anger at the
women that won't give them the time of
day
grows into a hateful ideology that
includes other groups of people as well
and then sometimes it even leads to
Violent real world actions so number one
it's important to understand that for
the vast majority of in cells that's not
actually the path they're not they're
not going to become violent that's not
what we're talking about they're just
folks struggling with isolation
sometimes it's self-esteem difficulty
forming romantic and sexual
relationships we should give them
compassion and support rather than
judging and condemning them as so many
people do on the internet so the
question is how can Society help in
cells what can actually be done
it's all pretty I don't want to say milk
toast stuff but what I mean is nothing's
going to be particularly titillating I
think we've all really kind of know what
needs to be done the resources and
support need to be there for people who
are struggling with either body image or
self-esteem issues that become this
feedback loop because of their
difficulty finding a partner
we we have to establish systems of
support for them that aren't belittling
or condescending we should encourage
people to seek out therapy or counseling
to try to work through the issues that
are underlying what often is a pretty
severe social anxiety either primary or
as a result of their lack of success
forming these relationships lack of
self-confidence sometimes there's past
traumas or a particularly acute event
where they were rejected by someone
which now has a subsequent feedback loop
and becomes a self-filling prophecy all
of that stuff may need to sort of be
worked through and so you've got to
offer education you have to think about
what resources can be established to
really think about how how do you
navigate dating how do you navigate
relationships how can you relate to
whoever it is that you consider to be in
your dating pool based on you know your
sexual orientation communication skills
understanding boundaries in some cases
helping people connect with not only
others like them
struggling with the same thing but also
with those that they would like to be
building relationships with and it could
be online it could be in person we're
not really doing this and it sort of
does fall under the umbrella of we need
to fund mental health the right loves to
say
this problem is mental health that
problem is mental health anything Gunner
violence related is definitely mental
health and then given the opportunity
they often opt not to properly fund
dealing with the mental health
components so we need to do that here
and again it's I know that it's very
popular to kind of just like make fun of
in cells or whatever you know it's just
kind of like ridicule it or see it as
not really a serious problem it's it's a
real serious problem in society because
it is a perpetuating mechanism a
feedback loop for anti-social behavior
that sometimes sometimes grows into
actual violent Acts send me your
thoughts about as specifically as
possible
what Canon should be done to support
these folks to hopefully allow them to
improve their lives